does he eat [__] and move on
[Music]
so how did you feel that guy you said
that you weren't attacked you at the
start how did you get to that point to
speak to him to then go on a date his
conversation literally I found him very
intriguing he was a like he was fresh
like last time he messaged you
send me a message like it was a
consecutive period of time where we were
speaking and I found him as an
interesting person and that's how it
kind of
I went on a date with him okay
um and also like attraction comes with
time like you get to know a person more
and if they've got a good personality
then they become more and more if they
meet you on the street or was it I think
no I was by a friend okay in person that
don't count because yeah
I'm saying that's different from a guy
on the street who is ugly a guy on
Instagram no no I was gonna say I was
going to say as well like if it's a guy
on the street a complete stranger
there's no there's no CV resume nothing
like and he's five foot free and looks
like Shrek and then he's like oh my God
you're so you're so gorgeous you're
gonna be like uh like like this station
you're not going to find out if he's got
a great character you're not gonna care
bro
that's the truth about it I'm just not
the type of person that would be
approached on the street and just be
okay with going on a date with you it
doesn't work for me like that okay but
you get what you get the point I'm
making that like that guy that you're
talking about who was unattractive that
you gave a chance to there was there was
a middle man do you get what I'm saying
there was someone that verified for him
yeah he's calming it and that gave him
the lies that gave the license for you
to even get to know him but if he was a
complete stranger like you met me today
and you thought oh this guy's ugly in
the corner like and I was like oh what's
your Instagram you'd be like I wouldn't
ugh sorry like me intrigue me yeah
I'm gonna give her a chance
because a lot of people sound trying to
stay in miles long but I'll tell you
something I I do things a bit
differently I don't go on dates I go on
meetings that means
before sexual there's a person which
means that if you keep looking at some
might be like oh my attracted in my mind
this you may sound the actual value
because that man the same way it could
be your husband it could be your best
friend it could be a business partner it
could be somebody so once you decline or
accept based on looks you'll screwing
yourself number one number two sometimes
as well the looks don't really matter
the person is really lovely you can do
it even out of like being a good person
you're kind you want to take me out why
am I saying no for no reason I'll go
with you but then you will know for sure
you're not for me I'll let you know your
friend zone Brother Zone family Zone
whatever Zone I need to put you in it's
very easy you create boundaries so you
can do whatever you want boundaries
create freedom and then lastly what was
the last question is do you gonna dates
oh the the the friend have you ever seen
okay go ahead I'm a very honest person
when my girls come to me and they start
telling me about the man first how did
he approach you what did he say what did
you say how did it go okay he's just
[__] you please stop telling me about
feelings and that's the first thing and
that's whether you're pretty or whether
you're a whale honesty
so a quick one for you like let's boil
it down to ruin this here yeah you got
eyes right so are you gonna sell because
the guy is not good looking so you're
settling basically you're basically
saying is that is it settling or is that
you're I'm going on meetings we look at
a relationship you have to be with
someone when you're tear their clothes
off and you've got personality match
right am I being wrong someone correct
me wrong that's more for men you know
really it might be no but yeah
I must be a man then woman you must be a
man whoever that is
you see women have that as well mostly
like bro let's be real like if you're
looking at a girl no yeah especially if
you're a so-called girl whatever yeah we
could be [__] we could be on the
airplane but you know what no no you
look at you like yo yo we need to go to
the bathroom yeah but why wouldn't you
why wouldn't you want that as a woman
where's my questions
anyone anyone in this room is not mind
Readers first thing we see is looks what
makes us know their personality beyond
that right yeah
you don't need to be a mind reader you
have to be a body language read and you
need to look people in the eyes and
question everything that they say first
you always know if you think whilst
people speaking to you'll always be
ahead of the game you have to play a
game because this is Art of Seduction I
believe in that book and it's taught me
a lot so love is the game
and I can have a conversation with
anyone and ask you about three questions
to make you be like oh you know she's
kind of nice she's quite interesting no
matter what your first impression of me
was one of them will be where are you
from because it shows that I'm kind of
showing any sort of interest in you I
can do whatever I want with you if I've
got a look I'm a woman I ask you the
right questions you think she's
generally interested men like girls are
also interested because they make them
seem easier so answer my question is
Love Again
love because the way you are subscribing
is listen love is one of those things
that there's an attraction but then you
need to secure the deal securing the
deal is the game what's the deal the
deal is making sure that the person is
aware that you love them and you love me
therefore we're gonna create something
and ask yourself persuasion yo yo yo you
you've got all this Insight in this
thing yeah are you are you currently
winning do you know why why I'm winning
because all the wrong ones is falling
off like so you have all this knowledge
you know every strategy you know exactly
what to do look in the eyes and all of
that Michael I made you smile so much
today
do you think you're winning I am winning
because realistically okay I'm not gonna
say realistically in my opinion are you
single and let me tell you something yes
do I win because I have to be in a
relationship the reason why I'm not in a
relationship is out of choice
let me let me ask you you said the
reason you're not in a relationship is
out of choice yeah so if you found the
perfect guy right now would you date him
yeah
something okay okay so wouldn't you say
that the guys you want then don't want
you no it's not that they don't want me
yeah
let me tell you something like I said to
you already for you to create a
relationship it takes you to tangle you
people at this you don't trust somebody
like that you have to test out you need
to make sure so what you do that's when
the game and the little dance is there
that's where the seduction play comes in
so all I'm saying is I'm winning because
every single time I get to suss out who
I want and who I don't want so I say I
don't want you but you are nice and
you're still interested if I want to do
like this tomorrow I can if I want to
open my legs and secure it quicker I can
but I don't want to so I'll take my time
it's better can I can I just say trust
is not repetition wow trust is benefit
of the doubt repetition is that you come
and you turn your light on and the light
works when you turn your light on it
don't work a million things go through
your head is it the light bulb that I
pay the bill am I having a power
shortage is the power out that's
repetition that's not a way to trust
somebody because the second they deviate
from that repetition that you are used
to you no longer trust that person and
it's hard and or impossible to get that
trust back trust is benefit of the time
are you challenging something that I
said are you just making a point both so
what do you challenge that I said
because you said you said it's again
it's do we trust each other do we go to
this I will put you through this
multiple things to see if I trust you
that's fine to do but what I'm telling
you is that's again goes back to and
again I'm telling you this because I'm
not trying to [__] you I'm telling you
the truth that is very easy to
manipulate from a man's point of view I
can make you think that what I'm doing
in my actions all the time are
trustworthy easy
but but what I'm saying to you I'm not
saying that you're wrong but what I'm
saying to you is benefit of the doubt
will work much better in this any
situation because the benefit of the
doubt is I'm not looking through your
phone because I [__] you wrong what's
the point of looking through your phone
if I don't trust you so let me tell you
something quickly
listen if let me tell you how it works
because
the point is the point is wait hold on
let's shoot these two elements
okay you're gonna let him speak now go
go go
what's the question okay I don't even
remember
obviously you have every pretty girl has
come on I'm ugly then what are you
trying to say that I'm ugly who's ugly
who said he's ugly
look at your skin you said every pretty
woman
I've never been on a free lunch you're
called Auntie for a reason
yeah
stop stop go go they're going go on
system I apologize
um I haven't gone out to get free food
I've gone out with somebody that I had a
friendship with that I didn't find
attractive but we was getting on so well
and I thought can I can this go anywhere
and then it confirms 100 no like there's
no attraction for me I know some women
can or some men might be able to wear
that I cannot lie that that date there
confirmed it and I was honest and I said
no because we was friends anyway it was
kind of like okay I think he was a bit
Latin word but he didn't express that to
me nobody appreciated your honesty but
um for me personally I have to be very
attracted or it's not gonna work like
it's just not gonna work what was the
things about him that like made you
unattracted to him what was it about him
that he didn't like like physically just
the way he looks
myself
he's just not my like I didn't feel like
yeah like it wasn't that it was just so
it was just his face really it's just
everything like the Justice Just build
everything I don't really okay obviously
someone shorter than me but I'm not like
if someone's a little bit taller than me
that don't bother me so a man don't need
to be told I know a lot of girls are
like no he has to be too I don't really
care about so can I ask a question If he
if he was blind and you went on a date
yeah that made him your perfect man then
if he's blind if he was blind yeah okay
I don't understand
and you went on that date with him was I
blind from birth yeah yeah I wouldn't
really know I wouldn't know about it
what I'm trying to say is that by the
way he sounded in the conversation
because you were friends and everything
yeah then it would have been perfect but
my eyes worked so it couldn't work
sorry anti-backer so what is what is
this physical attractions
what is this thing with like people
acting surprised that like women like
physically attracted it makes no sense
and the fact that you guys seem to over
emphasize one thing so women for
attraction and sexual attraction for
women is quite complex right women were
very hard to please they need atmosphere
they need a good conversation they need
good looks they need a good frame they
need Charisma level of status they need
all these things this is why
unattractive guys can constantly win as
you've seen in real life so why do we
come on these conversations and pretend
that like it's only because of looks and
like your shallow for doing this and
that when it's like well obviously she
gave him an opportunity to show these
other characteristics and most of the
time will fail because women are complex
right most guys don't have those other
characters because they're not obvious
so that's one thing I would say I think
on this matter I think is actually kind
of a good thing so I I haven't had much
experience with these kind of things
like paying for dinners and not getting
like you know smashing or whatever but
when I no no
I will tell you one thing my experience
of that was in uni first year I hit the
clubs and you know I hit the bar and you
know I watched all these American Pie
movies so I thought it was like yeah you
see someone cute you say hey can I get
you a drink try and have a chat in this
crowded busy stinky Club when you can't
hear each other and that's how it worked
in it so so this girl made eye contact
do you want to get a drink queued up
like 10 minutes got her this drink what
seven pound fifty it still hurt I was I
was in Union I was like
[Laughter]
I was like that was the dumbest thing
I've ever done that makes no sense so
you know when people when grown men are
like oh I took her out for dinner she
didn't smash it's like bro you could
have bought like a Twix or like a vodka
and figure that out but you didn't have
to do all that quick question for you to
so what for you you only would you only
go out on a date with someone that you
saw as a potential rather than just
someone you wanted to have fun with
that you see yourself getting into
something serious with down the line
I only have that but I think if I find
someone attractive and she acts right
then you know we will meet up and do
something but I I I refuse to take
anyone out or do anything like that
first I don't really pay for those I
don't I don't believe in that it's like
why do you believe in it it's 2022 bro
what equal right and and if you try it I
will start that conversation from the
start I'd be like all right so what do
you think about this oh it's crazy and
then when we're having dinner and you're
like looking at the bill I'd be like oh
are you so you're not you're not yeah
just before this podcast yeah I met up
with a friend and um like basically went
out for drinks yet if the girl yeah she
likes you she will offer to pay for a
round
if she doesn't offer she's not even bro
like you go to the party she's just
looking at her phone but she don't
really like you she don't really rate
you like that and if you want to steal
the deal and she offers you say no baby
I got you oh can I just disagree
the friend
that introduce you to the man you went
on a date with with male or female
friend it was actually a male
he read the room wrong
simple no I I honestly think that if it
was a male thinking about it if it was a
male
I think it would have worked
with effort and compromise I think it
would have worked I personally think
that you missed out I mean personally
like we we went into it we got into a
relationship okay oh that's all right
that's a relationship and we were
together for like two three years okay
no because what I'm saying is that women
lie to women
and if you'd been that day with your
checklist um
you know it wouldn't have worked no I
would I've I've been a date recommended
by a female and they always have other
issues so if it's a female don't trust
her
don't trust her at all and that's all
the thing that was going through my
brain is
I wonder if it was a female that
introduced you a male because if it's a
matter and that's what we need to do
stop vetting with your vagina and that's
your friends your male friends to vet
their men for you
even if it's the elders your brothers
your uncle other male friends and you
will find that you find better men if
you allow your men friends to vet them
forward because they know the truth
don't forget boys
um I was thinking what if we had someone
in this room pick who would be a good
person to date out of the people on the
piano
your sister okay your sister was here
okay okay who on the panel would you let
your sister date what out of the dudes I
thought you meant who would I pick up
dude to your sister's here first of all
everything she said is what I'm trying
to say it's literally what I was trying
to express is like I'm being honest with
you as a dude I'm gonna tell you the
truth I tell my sister I tell them the
truth
this is what he's doing this is why he's
doing it so who would I do yeah so who
who so yeah no go around like yes or no
to your sister dating though
uh dating like a relationship a
relationship like like she he she goes
on a day I said I went on a date with
this guy what do you think of him yes
yes
no yes what about TV yes and but for
reasons not because he's not a good dude
and not because he's not a good guy it's
not has nothing to do with that it has
to do with they are me
right I know where they are I know where
they've been I know what their mindset
is I know where he is I've had a private
conversation with him I know exactly
where he is this brother grows beards
he's got a very good mindset his
brother's looking for something
righteous so I get it zooby as well
uh me and zubi about to go do Joe Rogan
he only knows
so zubi I know but I there's a reason is
because I'm also I'm looking at not that
I care about my sisters like deeply I do
but I know them and their type and I
know
what their what they would say yes and
no to and how they would treat and what
they and who could handle that
that's what that is I also wouldn't put
them in a situation where I might
Dismount that's my sister bro like I'm
sorry yeah oh I want to say someone
okay okay
maybe yes yes definitely no definitely
no and I'd need to bet you okay yes
okay okay so I'm gonna change this as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible